Speaker 1: Let's go next. What are
we going to go next? Let's go to our
let's go to Matt from Arizona. Matt, I'm going
to be down in your neck of the woods very soon.
Matt, from Arizona, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: And then, right, that's you.
OK, I'm so sorry and that connection.
All right, David, jump in my question.
I want to utilize your master's degree.
I want to try and pick your brain. You know, a
lot of the issues in the country have to do with
money. Mm-Hmm. Money as a human concept to me that
we created that we can get rid of and we want to.
Obviously, it's not going anywhere. It creates
great structure. It creates slush, you know,
society. We have so much waste every year,
billions, millions, pounds, wasted food,
wasted resources, wasted anything. If we could.
We can make sure that everybody is doing well.
And as well, off to me, I could be
wrong. But were you using your message?
What would you say as far as you know? The debt
and deficit all human created we can get rid of,
we can embrace it basically. Like, who do we
owe? We have a debt. Who do we owe? One point,
however many trillions. I just
wanted to know your thoughts on that.
Speaker 1: So you're putting together a few
different issues, all of which are big. One
is the concept of money. Two is hunger
and food waste. Three is debt and deficit.
I'm not sure I totally know exactly what
you want me to weigh in on, necessarily.
Are you saying, can't we just say we don't know
anybody, any money or you're saying just digitally
alter the money supply to create the amount we
owe and then immediately pay it off? Or what?
Speaker 2: Definitely not the latter. Definitely
not that. Like, I understand, you know,
inflation and all that. But what I'm
saying is money is human created. Yes. So.
You know, who do we owe? If we could just
make sure that everybody is not going and
starving like there's little humans in America?
Speaker 1: But hold on. How does that? How does
the hunger issue relate to the WHO?
Do we owe issue? I'm not. I don't
know that I understand the connection.
Speaker 2: It had to be do do more like,
you know, this really opened my eyes around
pandemic time. The heart of the pandemic. Food
lines in America. Yeah. You know, sending
out stimulus checks to make sure people,
you know, don't go hungry. You know,
we could just be giving people food,
or we could just be making sure people have a
house to live in. Yes, or don't agree to does. So,
you know, we have the resources we have, you know,
everything that a human would need and accommodate
every human on the planet at the same time. Yes.
So, you know, like, we have all these issues,
but they're human created issues like I don't.
Speaker 1: Yeah. All right, Matt. Listen, you're
bringing up important issues. I'm not actually
sure that there's really a question for me to
answer there. So I'm going to let you go. But very
important, you've identified important issues, and
I think they are issues that we should be looking
into very strongly for lack of a better term.